hey guys and welcome back to steampunks
GameSpot's pc focus show featuring
myself just mcdonald and in madrid
that's me sir this is a sure we talk
about pc games pc type things and pc
issues which is pretty much what we're
digging into today you guys probably
know about a little game called full ass
76 not everyone's favorite game of the
year but certainly a big game that came
out but we're not going to talk about
the the overall criticism what we do
want to talk about is the controls on pc
confounding yeah so i played a lot of
476 and i played on pc and i was
swapping between keyboard and mouse and
controllers right because i found that
the pc controls a little weird not the
best implementation of keyboard and
mouse control in a PC game if you ask me
now Bethesda I know has their little
quirks there's a PC controls but they're
not good quirks and them being in
previous games does not make it fine
yeah it's interesting actually because
it's the tester I've done this with a
few different things it's just like if
it ain't completely broke let's just
keep it the same like it's totally
sprite
no not totally but functional what I
would do I would liken it to something
like the way Bethesda keeps implementing
its inventory system it's our PJs look
it's fine things are basically in
categories but if any of you have been
playing for 76 and trying for the life
of you joy and even as the game real o
or a knee and dig through the aid
category to find something that Olaf
eyes as water or any kind of liquid
because your character is parched
these things aren't passed out properly
which is why they tend to end up getting
mods from the community to improve them
yeah so the biggest concern with the
controls in slide 76 for me initially
there are a few but the first one for me
was tab is back again
and it makes no sense because if you
play any PC game if you use your PC at
all if you you know browse the Internet
or whatever you know that escape is
always back yeah
and for some reason it's some menus wait
some mean use it's okay so this is what
really gets me with 476 controls in some
menus like I'm pretty for sure for
example the building menu yeah get out
of the building menu its escape it's
good to get out of any other menu it's
tab mr. so there's no consistency there
which is a few years yeah and I mean the
now we have to talk about the melee
button everybody really gets my good so
the melee button in floor 36 is by
default assigned to alt which is a
really weird one but what's also
confusing is that alt is also assigned
to your grenade button so you have to
press and hold alt to charge a grenade
not V like any other like a third person
first-person game on PC but oh and it's
obviously a whole liver from the console
configuration on the controller where by
holding like r1 or the right trigger has
a dual function but it just doesn't make
a lot of sense and if you use an Nvidia
card like take screenshots or like
capture gameplay footage that really
messes with your own yeah if you're
capturing ability and it's also like you
have to hit T to skip cinematics yeah T
of all buttons not escape or space or
anything like that
fallout 76 is more of a real-time thing
you do need to have a lot of different
things Maps
yeah a lot of different buttons but even
so it's it's all about the ease of
accessibility in terms of your functions
in terms of like grabbing weapons
quickly like being up at the heart of
your weapons yeah and moving it out
because the minions aren't pause you
need to have everything like make a lot
of sense
right and it took me a lot of time to
sort of get my head around what the
keyboard layout was you know obviously
to its credit you know you can remap
anything you want and that's certainly
what I did but still it they obviously
designed the new Fallout 4 to be a
console experience and there are a lot
of sort of affordances there made
or controller mapping well it seems like
they didn't really spend a ton of time
thinking about how it would be best
implemented into a keyboard and mouse
situation there's also pretty evident in
the way that they've designed the UI and
sort of the the menus and all that kind
of stuff the scrolling thing you know
doesn't really work well of keyboards
it's all about tabs and you know having
the idea of that the way the pip-boy
laid out kind of suits the shoulder
button sort of lay up way more and so I
find myself with not just with fall out
but with a lot of PC games these days
just reverting to a controller
configuration because it seems like
they're just all designed yeah
troll it in mind they're designed to
have you always have your fingers
hovering above certain buttons to be
able to quickly go back and forth the
biggest didn't take away from this is
that if you play a lot of games on PC
especially a lot of third person games
or City games that require analog
control yeah like for example racing
games you should probably like invest in
the controller and feel comfortable in
using a controller because keyboard and
mouse is great and like the first-person
shooters like nothing beaten but
strategy games nothing beats it yeah
that the fact that the PC is getting a
lot more games that were traditionally
console only and that includes new games
like things like hell-blade and yeah the
new double make cry and also all games
so old Capcom and Sega reporting on what
their old sort of ps3 ps4 only games to
PC now you've got your Resident Evil's
you've got like the Yakuza series they
should have keyboard and mouse
implementation of course you know
accessibility you need to be able to
play with anything but if you do want
the original experience you should
probably be okay with plugging an Xbox
or a PlayStation controller into your
console see that disappoints me because
I feel like this should be I mean full
76 is a great example there is a better
way to have optimized that keyboard
layout that made sense okay so you want
to play keyboard and mouse although like
I have to admit with games I've
encountered like Alice madness Returns
and hell-blade those games just bought
you the entire time you tried to play
them with a keyboard right Mouse which
is a shame but because of their nature
as action games I just it's really
engaging with combat in those games that
I just did
think works with the constraints of was
basically not being able to have
joysticks not having like as such such
intricate control over exactly where you
are at any point yeah platformers are a
nightmare as I'm sure any of you would
know yeah as the water began to rise
Clare vowed to save this little
rectangle in as many restarts as it took
you have to you remember that a lot of
these games I design with analog sticks
and mine which have a granularity to
exactly you know how far you push a
stick or how hard you press the button
people forget that the Xbox has like you
know analog triggers and you know
PlayStation 3 had analog triggers so you
could like hold down it's really hard
and the game would recognize that and
you don't have that with PC it's either
on or off being a PC game it doesn't
mean you need to be a keyboard and mouse
Zeebo to you and you know if people tell
me off for that but you know the BC is
always used peripherals and accessories
like think about I think back to like
the 90s when myself and my brother we
were playing flight Sims I'm gonna buy a
flight sim on a keyboard a clay you're
gonna buy a flight stick I mean Jess
you've always been super stubborn about
using keyboard and mouse only oh yeah
hey but you've had to have you've had to
adapt yeah well I mean I did finish
hell-blade with keyboard and mouse yeah
huge and I wouldn't recommend it but
yeah I mean I know what it's like to
just be like no I just want to stick
with my keyboard mouse but I think
sometimes you have to concede that to
get the best gameplay experience
sometimes will be with a controller and
not keyboard I think the best gameplay
experience is whatever the game has been
designed from the ground up yeah there
are certain game like me up both right
like XCOM 2 is like a good example yeah
a game working really well a controller
and working really well on keyboard and
mouse as well but those are kind of few
and far between
but if you have any examples of things
of the games that do both well do you
let us know in the comments and if
something fails it either platform let's
move out as well
well are you thinking about your
comments for this episode we did want to
thank you for your comments on our last
episode which is when on earth is Red
Dead Redemption to coming to PC we think
it's soon one year you guys were really
kind of all over the place we did get a
comment from est 84 X who said render
dungeon 2
coming to PC seems very certain given
online is rockstar's
money printing machine that said we
thought Red Dead Redemption being ported
was a certainty back in the day too
I actually think they might even
surprise us all by bundling both games
and bringing them to PC sometime next
year seems odd to just release a game
sequel now I thought this one was really
interesting because I would have put
money on the fact that they were going
to remaster the first Red Dead for PC
right before they brought out they say
yeah I thought that was gonna happen so
for sure yeah I think hey I think they
might have a bigger plan than mine I
mean obviously what he said about online
being a money printing machine for
Rockstar is completely true there yeah
I'm not gonna deny like one of the
bigger uses biggest user bases and I
think sooner if not later it's gonna
have it I think what's more likely if
we're just gonna do red death
speculation yeah is that they're going
to basically remake Red Dead Redemption
in the Red Dead Redemption to engine
because you know if he there's a - poly
and there are certain parts of the Red
Dead Redemption one map in - so that we
made those areas and they have sweet
character models they obviously have
John Marston in the game you know he's
part of your camp part of your vanderlin
gang so that's probably more likely
murder of redemption one was like on a
really sort of old engine and you know
putting that stuff to PC you know is
probably not worth the money when you
can just make something nice and shiny
expensive expensive yeah they make that
money from online everyone YouTube Shay
said I went ahead and bought the game on
xbox 1x apparently looks better on the X
and the pro question mark yeah it
probably does anyway I really wish I was
on PC and if they ever do bring it to PC
I will rebuy it this is exactly exactly
my sentiments exactly you know that's
exactly what I did with Grand Theft Auto
you know reg of redemption is a great
game and one that I honestly would not
mind playing again especially on you
know a PC that you know it grows yeah in
capabilities this is a comment I really
wanted to highlight because there was a
lot of arguing in all that we've
received a lot of comments on this video
yeah over there buying it like basically
strategy that rocks there seems to be
going for yes just aiming that there was
a lot of people like this being like
like I hate it but I'm gonna rebuy and a
lot of people who are just really angry
that they seem to be pursuing this
trying to push people in to repine yeah
you begin with as a result I just like
no I'm not getting it on console like
that yeah it's it's sneaky as hell that
it's disappointingly something that I
think I wanted to do or do yeah but you
know on the bright side if I put so much
time at the red redemption - but I don't
kind of mind buying it again you know I
know people want to get a lot of value
for their one purchase but I find
shopping another life 50 bucks and again
that I spend hundreds of hours on I
think that's exactly every night I hear
you I mean they're all oh you guys
saying you just don't have consoles and
if it comes to VC you'll play it and
otherwise you just don't play a game on
console
stick to your guns and your own
definition of value that's right well
that's all for this episode of steampunk
thank you for your comments and do let
us know what games you think implement
keyboard and mouse well and what games
do not I would love to see a list of
really bad PC control yeah anyway until
next time
[Music]